[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans un point de
vue ça plaisir de vous retrouver
je me sens en pleine forme d'autant que
j'ai deux médecins autour de moi donc
c'est quelque chose ne va pas ils
pourront intervenir des médecins qui
sont aussi des observateurs affûté de
notre vie publique bonsoir patrick
pelloux comment ça vous êtes médecin
urgentiste attaché à l'hôpital necker à
paris
c'est aussi le président de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france avait été longtemps
chroniqueur à charlie hebdo et
votre dernier livre urgence de vivre aux
éditions du cherche midi est d'ailleurs
un recueil de ses chroniques merci exact
bon ce soir laurent alexandre soir vous
êtes vous à votre médecin et
entrepreneurs essayiste votre dernier
livre jouissez jeunesse a été publié aux
éditions lattès
on va donc commencer par parler bien sûr
de la crise sanitaire je voudrais vous
montrer ces images vous les avez
peut-être déjà vu elles ont été tournées
hier aux pays bas et elle nous montre
des scènes d'une grande violence
il y avait une manifestation contre le
couvre-feu
le couvre-feu qui était en vigueur
depuis samedi dernier au pays basque est
une première depuis la fin de la
première guerre mondiale et ses
manifestations ont tourné à l'émeute
dans plusieurs villes notamment à
amsterdam et eindhoven et regardez ce
qu'a déclaré à la télévision le maire
d'eindhoven john joritz ma je pense que
si nous continuons sur ce chemin nous
allons vers une guerre civile
laurent alexandre comment est-ce que
vous analysez ce genre de réaction qui
n'ont pas du tout lieu en france où
l'acceptation de toutes les règles
contraignantes confinement couvre-feu
ont l'air mieux acceptés ou est ce que
vous croyez que le feu peut couver sous
la braise par le feu couve partout mais
c'est assez étonnant parce que les
hollandais sont en général des gens très
calmes pas du tout des excités comme les
français et donc c'est étonnant de voir
qu'il y ait des révoltes qui arrive en
europe du nord avec la sociologie que
l'on connaît de l'europe du nord
c'est inattendu mais ce refus des
nouveaux confinement ce refus du
maintien des mesures liberticides fate
est une tendance de fond or avec
l'arrivée des nouveaux variants la
moindre efficacité peut-être des vaccins
sur certains variants même si on en est
pas encore sûr comme le variant sud
africain en réalité nous ne sommes pas
sortis d'affaires et la pénurie en
europe de vaccins empêche d'imaginer une
sortie de crise rapide par la
vaccination
donc il va falloir accepter des mesures
coercitives pendant longtemps et donc
l'équation politique va être très très
très difficile il va y avoir des
débordements ce qu'on a vu à amsterdam
peut arriver dans n'importe
villes d'europe y compris d'europe du
sud à tout moment vous vivez à bruxelles
est-ce que là bas c'est tendu aussi
quand comment est l'état d'esprit en
belgique c'est assez rigoureux les
mesures prises là bas notamment pour le
pour la liberté de voyager
vous savez la querelle entre les
francophones et les néerlandophones
consomme une telle une tellement grande
partie de l'énergie des belges que après
ils n'ont plus d'énergie pour se battre
sur d'autres sujets ça suffit à les
occuper année après année en plus
pendant un an et demi
le roi n'a pas réussi à former un
gouvernement est là o'meara qu'il y ait
un nouveau gouvernement donc les gens ne
vont pas se révolter face à ce nouveau
gouvernement qu'ils ont enfin je vous
donne les points de vue de nos
internautes d'abord la question twitter
troisième confinement pénurie de vaccins
craignez-vous la révolte des français
c'est oui à 54%
voici des réactions être et savoir sur
twitter qui nous dit clairement je ne
crains pas la révolte je la souhaite et
je l'attends
bon bah voilà paul sur twitter 2021 sera
le nouveau 1789 et il ya d'autres
internautes qui sont nettement moins
alarmiste par exemple d'oddo sur youtube
qui nous dit avoir les files d'attentes
devant les boutiques pendant les soldes
la révolte est loin très loin voilà donc
le débat le débat fait rage vous
continuez à vous exprimer sur twitter
sur lefigaro.fr et sur youtube
alexandre
sur youtube justement nous dit c'est
probable qu'il y ait des manifestations
mais je ne pense pas qu'elles auront de
l'ampleur parce que beaucoup de gens
acceptent les mesures
même s'il souffre alors que carole sur
youtube estime elle que après deux
confinement un troisième serait la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
combien d'entreprises vont fermer se
demande-t-elle c'est ça le plus
important
patrick peloux vous n'êtes pas devin
mais qu'est ce que vous ressentez on
reviendra après un sur les vaccins mais
de réaction des français et de leur
acceptabilité deux de ces mesures de
contrainte avec ce troisième confinement
qui s'annonce le le truc c qui aurait
pensé qu' au moment du premier
confinement les françaises et français
répondent aussi intelligemment à ces
contraintes toute nouvelle qui arrive
est en fait ils ont obéi
ils sont restés chez eux ils ont arrêté
les voyages on a arrêté d'aller à
l'école
bon ça eu des conséquences mais on
pouvait au départ personne pense elle
tout le monde disait on est roublard le
président de la république qui nous
traitent maintenant deux procureurs
enfin bon voilà bon non non les gens au
pays bon c'est une situation historique
on n'est pas près d'arrêter ce qui est
en train de se passer
mais il ne faut pas souhaiter qu'il y
ait une révolte
d'accord ça donnerait quoi ça donnerait
conca serait tout ce qu'on a
d'institutionnels les hôpitaux etc on
s'empêcherait de travailler vous
imaginez et une révolte contre quoi
contre un virus
à la bonne heure c'est à dire qu'en fait
on va se battre sur quelque chose qui
est quasiment invisible à l'oeil nu
d'accord non ce qu'il faut c'est au
contraire faire preuve d'intelligence
c'est ce que le gouvernement doit
entendre et on a besoin de politiques
alors on a besoin de politiques alors
c'est là où il faut qu'ils se réveillent
un petit peu parce qu'on a besoin de
politiques pour donner du sens à ce qui
se passe et comment on construit
l'avenir
à très court terme et moyen terme parce
que c'est pas près de s'arrêter
d'accord là on va revivre un confinement
d'accord parce qu'en effet vous avez les
variants qui sont arrivés comme disait
alexandre ils sont
nombreux et on a énormément de doutes il
ya beaucoup de choses que je ne sais pas
qu'on ne sait pas comment ça va évoluer
pour vous n'y a pas de doute leur
confinement il est il est à couy oui il
est il est acquis il faut freiner coûte
que coûte ce qui est en train de se
passer là les décors par exemple en ile
de france sont comme ça il ya des
nouvelles qui peuvent faire peur par
exemple ce qui se passe dans certaines
zones au brésil ou au brésil à cause de
leurs fous qui est président la bo
solaro il a décidé de rien faire donc en
fait c'est un modèle d'épidémiologie
incroyable puisque en fait on a laissé
faire le virus
qu'as tu es à un nombre de gens
absolument incroyable et là on
s'aperçoit quoi c'est que le variant qui
arrive repasse à nouveau sur les malades
qui pourtant avait une immunité donc
tout ça c'est inquiétant faut prendre ça
avec des pincettes faut pas avoir peur
parce que on a quand même des avantages
l'a déjà fait un tour de piste on a déjà
fait une année là dessus donc on
commence à bien connaître à bien savoir
s'organiser et ça c'est important on
sait mieux soigner cette maladie et donc
il faut pas perdre de vue une chose
importante en termes de médecine sait
qu'il ya les autres malades du
coronavirus il faut pas les oublier
d'accord il ya des malades infarctus
tout ça les cancers faut pas les oublier
irrités de ne pas devoir l'art et les
services de réanimation voilà et et
surtout de ne pas encourager de quelque
forme que ce soit un état ou un système
qui révèrent la révolte et la
désorganisation du système
on a tous à y perdre dans un truc comme
ça
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
appelé cette fois la partie des missions
craignez-vous la révolte
évidemment on ne la souhaitent pas
laurent alexandre peut-être que s'il n'y
a pas de réaction violente en france
c'est parce que le respect des règles il
est un peu aléatoire par exemple il ya
un couvre-feu théoriquement à partir de
18 heures on voit encore beaucoup de
gens dans les rues à 18 heures on dit
qu'il ya beaucoup de dents droit de type
restaurants ou bars qui en fait sont pas
complètement fermé comme si cette espèce
de d'arrangement avec la règle
permettait de d'évacuer la pression
c'est votre point de vue c'est une
cocotte minute
si on empêche
tout air de sortir de la cocotte-minute
on va là effectivement avoir des
révoltes et comme le disait patrice le
problème si les gens se révoltent
globalement contre les mesures c'est
qu'on va avoir deux cent mille morts
supplémentaires parce que se révolte et
bien sûr ses fils et ses fermes et libre
de quoi c'est faire les rave parties
or les nouveaux variants semble un peu
plus dangereux même si on n'en est pas
encore certain
autour de 40 % de mortalité
supplémentaire donc pour avoir une
immunité collective avec les nouveaux
variants on est plus à 350 400 mille
morts on pourrait peut-être monter à 500
600 mille morts donc et puis si on est
si on peut faire plusieurs variants de
suite
on pourrait même imaginer d'être au delà
de ce nombre de morts pour arriver à
limiter collective donc c'est
inacceptable la seule chose qu'on peut
faire c'est d'avoir une stratégie
optimum de confinement c'est d'essayer
au maximum de trouver de nouvelles doses
vaccinales mais c'est difficile parce
que l'europe a vraiment très mal négocié
par rapport à des pays comme comme
israël et puis l'angleterre et même les
états unis
et puis il va falloir se poser des
questions très difficiles dans les
semaines qui viennent s'il se confirme
que certains nouveaux variants sont
résistants vaccin il va falloir tout de
suite
fabriquer une version 2.0 des vaccins
arn messagers et peut-être switch est
relativement rapidement vers les
nouvelles formes de vaccin qui protège
contre les différents variant c'est une
décision très difficile à prendre parce
que même pour faire un vaccin arn
messagers on estime qu'il faut sans
jouer en mai et donc on n'aura pas ces
nouveaux vaccins mais avec l'âge et
comme celui de pfizer et de moderne mais
mais mais c'est là où il va falloir à un
moment donné quand même que les
puissants de ce monde se réunissent pour
dire on va déconnecté quand même le côté
commercial des vaccins du besoin pour
l'humanité parce que là on va pas
pouvoir laisser father faire la pluie et
le beau temps sur le marché du vaccin
dont dont tous les pays du monde vont
avoir besoin
attention parce que ça dans d'autres
temps ça aurait pu être une déclaration
de guerre soit dit en passant
donc le truc c'est que vraiment le
vaccin soit universelle qu'on nous
permette
et ça c'est la souveraineté de la france
ou de l'europe de fabriquer ce vaccin en
grande quantité
c'était notre notre notre débat
il ya quinze jours et c'est très
important quand on sait qu'il ya des
chaînes de production en france qui
serait capable de fabriquer ce vaccin et
que juste on attend que une
technostructure qui va mettre à peu près
2 à 3 mois de réfléchir pour donner les
bons tampons c'est là où on se dit c'est
là on a besoin de sens politique
pourquoi le président de la république
dit page réquisitionne ses usines
on récupère les brevets de chez pfizer
et on le fabrique nous on peut le
fabriquer je me suis renseigné on peut
le fabriquer donc c'est vraiment hyper
important parce que si on n'a pas assez
de souveraineté lala cette semaine on va
reparler du vaccin mais peut-être cette
semaine il ya des hôpitaux on a plus de
doses alors n'a pas vu de dos parlons-en
du vaccin parce que vous dites il y en a
pas assez
d'ailleurs vous êtes de passer pour le
thé parce que vous êtes vous maintenant
l'ailière genevois à l'hôtel-dieu en
renfort pour distribuer les lits pour
inoculer pas dans les magasins si c'est
comme ça qu'on dit injecté je leur les
injecter qui est vous avez eu cette
déclaration assez inquiétante quand même
un cd chez nos confrères de bfm tv
la situation est explosive avez vous dit
on n'est pas à l'abri des meutes pour se
faire vacciner oui oui oui c'est ce que
j'ai vu les vous savez contrairement à
ce qu'on a dit les gens veulent se faire
vacciner
d'accord les gens veulent ce vaccin ce
vaccin ils savent que les doses
maintenant sont rares et là a priori on
a reçu des messages à la fois de
l'assistance publique de l'agencé
régionale de santé du ministère disant
ouhlala nous n'avons plus de doses et si
j'ai bien compris ça vient de finder
caddie qui diminuait ses envois cette
semaine bon les gens ont bien compris
l'importance du vaccin
ils ont bien compris ils veulent se
faire vacciner
donc d'un coup on peut pas leur mentir
ce qui fait qu'en effet vous avez des
gens qui sont dans la file d'attenté
moi je l' ai vu un couple qui sont venus
le monsieur était inscrit il est venu
avec sa femme faut le comprendre il dit
moi je vais être vacciné je veux que mon
épouse soient vaccinés et sa entraîné
une querelle très complexe et moi je
l'accepté mais moi j'ai dit on le
vaccine de quel droit je vais refuser un
vaccin à cette dame
d'accord c'est pas moi qui suis d'accord
moi je suis mais pas parce qu'elle n'est
pas mariée que j'arrive fumée de sa
d'accord c'est chacun son tour on est
inscrits mais vous avez d'un coup une
dame
voilà il y avait des audi avait des
doses d'un coup vous vous dites vous
fait oeuvre d'humanité pour calmer les
choses sinon il allait se battre et
c'est donc ça qu'il faut voir que les
rendez vous soit prévu que tout le monde
puisse s'inscrire sur des sites qui
fonctionnent
c'est hyper important parce que sinon là
on pourra toujours à on pourrait
toujours avoir des lumières et envoyer
des signaux à batman pour qu'il vienne
nous aider il y en a pas batman n'existe
pas donc d'un coup il nous faut des
doses
il nous faut du vaccin il faut qu'on
puisse vacciner les gens c'est hyper
stratégiques ce qui fait que ça revient
sur votre première question si on re
confine faut que ça soit donnant donnant
c'est à dire on leur dit on vous
reconfirme trois semaines mais il va y
avoir une date et on va pouvoir vacciner
et m'a alors là je ne suis pas comme des
frais si ouvert en moi je dis qu'il faut
vacciner tout le monde sauf sauf bien
sûr les enfants mais il faut vaincre
condition d'avoir assez de doses laurent
exemple de se disaient vous êtes
entrepreneur vous connaissez bien ce
secteur de la delà des biotechnologies
ce serait une solution de réquisitionner
ses laboratoires pour ses traits plus de
ré très très difficile un terme de
transfert de propriété intellectuelle
d'adaptation des usines ça prendrait
beaucoup beaucoup de temps moi je ne
crois pas qu'il soit réaliste d'imaginer
que les usines en france puissent
produire le vaccin moderna ou pfizer
pour des raisons légales de propriété
intellectuelle et d'adaptation des
origines casser ça faut casser ça ça
prendrait la droite est mais une yaris
est comme le dit bernard y ait une effet
la tendance elle l'a toujours été très
forte ma maman à 89 ans est là son
premier rendez-vous de de vaccination
pour la première dose le 27 mai 27 mai
27 dans quelles villes comme à paris à
paris 27 mai la ja comme il ya plus de
doses
les rendez-vous sont retarder retarder
retarder donc là vraiment il va falloir
qu'on réfléchisse à la stratégie
européenne l'europe dit on veut pas
surpayer les doses
eh bien on aurait intérêt à faire ce
qu'a fait israël de payer plus cher les
doses pour en avoir tout de suite parce
que le résultat des courses et
qu'aujourd'hui on va avoir des
confinement long parce qu'on n'est pas
capable de vacciner les gens et on va
conduire à des situation de désespérance
jeu qu'on avait dix à quinze jours est
toujours vrai 1
netanyahu a passé dix sept coups de
téléphone personnel au président de
failles mais selon pour avoir ces doses
à si l'europe les payer plus cher
elle pourrait en avoir davantage sur l
faut elle pourrait être prioritaire mais
comme a été israël israël et l'englobé
moins nombreux quand même
l'angleterre a eu des noces par exemple
en les payant et les états unis ont pré
payées les doses de plusieurs milliards
de dollars pour en avoir plus que rob
donc en réalité il ya des pays non mais
qui ont eu des stratégies plus agressive
et qui ont eu les doses en premier mais
alexandre patrick le galloudec semblant
rendre son prénom voilà laurent pardon
ça se faire excuser moi laurent le le le
le truc c'est justement là il s'agit
d'une survie quelques parle de
l'humanité d'accord on en est là on en
est là c'est évident que si le virus
mute sans arrêt avec des formes qui
résistent et c'est bien sûr qu'il faudra
fabriquer voilà mes devoirs unis
auraient même orgueil en avoir alors
luttons qui donne à ce que je veux dire
par là c'est qu'à un moment donné il
faut que vraiment la fabrication et les
propriétés intellectuelles et de
recherche soit universelle c'est c'est
sauver l'humanité on n'est pas là pour
dire et faveur d'un coup qui joue donc
finalement une certaine offre entre la
demande et l'offre d'accord il joue ça
ils augmentent les prix pour en donner
plus
je trouve que c'est pas juste etc et
c'est injuste pour les autres le plus
injuste le problème est là le problème
qu'à la france c'est que de tous les
grands pays la france et le sol qui n'a
pas réussi à avoir un vaccin
c'est à dire que le vaccin pasteur a
planté et pasteur arrête et le vaccin
sanofi il sera prêt à noël prochain
c'est-à-dire après la bataille
donc en réalité la production française
de vaccins qui aurait dû avoir lieu n'a
pas lieu alors pour la série la raison
que les deux voies qui ont été choisis
par les champions français pasteur et
sanofi non à ceux à ce jour pas marché
aussi bien que la voie est raide ou même
que la voix astrazeneca ray une partie
des chercheurs qui travaillent aux états
unis sont français comme baïkal à bord
six nations ils sont pas dans la zone
comment ce n'est pas le regard moderne
qui a paniqué à la patronne le dernier
comme le premier et on ne voyait que les
garder et génial de faire des vaccins à
ccc arn messager c'est là où c'est là
l'importance de la souveraineté du pays
mais savez vous en fait c'est une crise
ici à mort
d'euskadi bancel le français qui dirige
moderna ils avaient négocié avec les
autorités françaises
ils étaient prêts à donner des doses à
la france et puis la france a interrompu
les négociations avec modern a alors
même que son président étaient français
et donc avait une proximité culturelle
avec les autorités réglementaires
françaises très forte on va sûrement
revenir sur sur ce sujet parce que
l'attention ne risque pas de diminuer
surtout après que ce qu'avec ce que vous
nous apprenez patrick pleau dire que à
paris à l'ap-hp on en a de moins en
moins de deux mois dans mon dos et ça
c'est la réalité la pénurie phase 2 qui
s'annonce
quelques derniers commentaires de nos
internautes que ce sujet passionne comme
nous tous alexandre sur youtube c'est
probable qu'il y ait des manifestations
mais je ne pense pas qu'elles seront
d'ampleur parce que beaucoup de gens
acceptent le mesure même s'ils souffrent
et il ya les internautes hostiles au
confinement qui sont assez nombreux qui
s'exprime sur le figaro.fr
nathan 770 il ne faut pas confiné c'est
inutile et nuisible kriss kross ça va
péter c'est sûr
you may 69 toujours selon le figaro.fr
la révolte serait saine et salutaire et
je termine avec
cette préconisation de christophe 78
toujours sur lefigaro.fr
il va bien falloir une autre stratégie
que le confinement et le vaccin wilshere
chrysler soit 118 sauf que pour
l'instant de stratégies alternatives
changeant complètement de sujets si vous
le voulez bien pour reparler de cette
agression extrêmement violente elle a eu
lieu il ya une dizaine de jours mais on
a connu que en fin de semaine dernière
la vidéo qui montre l'agression de
lloris et un adolescent qui a été
attaqué dans des conditions d'une
barbarie inédite en plein paris sur la
dalle du quartier de beaugrenelle c'est
dans le 15e arrondissement
est-ce que ont franchi de nouvelles
étapes dans ce qu'on appelle
l'ensauvagement de sociétés françaises
ça nous intéressera d'avoir votre point
de vue écoutez pour commencer si vous le
voulez bien celui du maire de
l'arrondissement
il est il appartient en partie les
républicains et philippe goujon bailly
n'en revient toujours pas de ce qui
s'est passé
certains ont des difficultés à dire ce
qui s'est passé la peur de représailles
le traumatisme de cette affaire
gravissime sans précédent dans le xvème
à vous avez vous l'avais dit dans votre
annonce c'est un quartier réputé
tranquille le 15e et donc c'est sans
précédent ces tags d'audience et sans
précédent d'une barbarie inouïe mais
malheureusement se rend compte depuis
quelques temps que peut-être des des
problèmes entre jeunes je ne dis pas que
c'est un affrontement entre bandes ans
c'est pas ça s'est passé encore mais on
voit bien que des affrontements entre
jeunes qui autrefois se régler à coups
de poings ou avec des injures des
insultes aujourd'hui se règle à coups de
batte de baseball de béquilles de
marteau sur l'aide de coups de marteau
sur la tête
voilà parce que c'est effectivement ce
qui s'est passé patrick pleau on dit
souvent que les urgences est une espèce
de deux postes avancés pour scruter la
société vous vous la sentez vous cette
montée de la violence
ouais ça fait ça fait des années ça fait
des années qu'on le voit monter avec des
notamment des jeunes c'est ça qui est le
plus triste qui sont sans repères
je pense qu'on a on a toute une
réflexion à avoir sur l'échec scolaire
et l'absentéisme scolaire c'est ça part
de là 1 je me souviens juste une
parenthèse mais au moment du procès de
charlie hebdo lé des deux mines d'atr
commun de tous les terroristes c'était
le fait qu'ils ont eu une rupture
scolaire très très très très rapide il
n'y a pas de petite délinquance
j'en suis convaincu faut arrêter de dire
petite délinquance en fait il faut
vraiment aller sur la racine du mal il
ya une racine social c'est évident il ya
des familles qui sont désoeuvrés qui ne
savent plus souvent qu'ils sont 3ème
4ème génération les a abandonnés quand
ils sont venus construire les
reconstruire la france dans les années
60 et on a continué on n'a pas su
travailler sur sur ce sur ce qu'on avait
le devoir humaniste de travailler sur
l'éducation la culture dans ces zones là
ce qui fait qu en effet nous on a vu aux
urgences monter cette violence est une
violence mais en effet comme dit le
maire du 15e avant c'était des taloches
des claques des coups de poing
maintenance et de la barre de fer
maintenant ils sont armés aussi et c'est
des coups de couteau on en fait
régulièrement
donc on sait pas ce qui s'est passé donc
ça ne sert à rien de dire des choses ou
d'interpréter c'est juste que ce que
vous voyez là c'est ce que nous on
entend alors c'est un peu diminué mine
de rien avec le confinement avec les
mesures et c'est ça a diminué
je voudrais pas dit la même chose il ya
un an mais en gros les bagarres entre
jeunes
les bagarres entre jeunes d'accord
c'était notre lot quotidien les
vendredis les vendredis les samedis et
des fois le jeudi parce que c'était la
soirée des étudiants et c'est très
inquiétant
c'est très inquiétant et on peut je
pense qu'on peut encore faire quelque
chose parce qu'on peut encore faire
quelque chose il faut comprendre où est
ce qu'on a ou a eu ce qu'on a perdu le
contact avec la cette jeunesse qu'il n'a
comme repère finalement que des en fait
d'aider des moyens pour vivre qui sont
souvent liés au trafic de drogue qui
pensent que d'aller à l'école ça sert à
rien qu'ils pensent que la culture ça
sert à rien on a perdu il faut faire un
éloge de la politesse par exemple qu'on
a perdu faut faire l'éloge du vivre
ensemble et tout ça c'est pas
s'arc-bouter sur dire il faut plus de
répression
c'est quelque chose de global bien sûr
faux de la répression bien sûr qu'il
faut que la police intervienne
il faut comprendre ce qui s'est passé
mais vous savez il ya des quartiers dans
paris ou vraiment c'est des bandes qui
font qu'ils font là qui font la loi faut
comprendre nous quand on intervient avec
le samu et qu'on monte dans certains
immeubles
on sait qu'on a en bas des tours il ya
généralement on nous laisse passer parce
qu'ils savent que c'est l'amitié
d'espacé mais si on vient avec la police
ça devient un petit peu plus difficile
vous voyez on retombe sur ce que dit
souvent les syndicats de police et que
d'un coup vous avez en fête des
quartiers qu'on a abandonné il faut
aller les rechercher
il va vous emparer en train de mettre en
paris intra muros c'est le 19e
engagement d'avoir 19 et 20 19 et 20
est-ce que c'est trop tarder en annexant
jamais de 2 jamais jamais jamais jamais
l'auteur mamie jamais trop tard de façon
si on laisse ce faire la fin du livre du
vivre ensemble
accepte une communautarisation agressive
et qu'on abandonne des populations à des
ghettos violent on va vers des
situations qui pourraient déboucher sur
des situations de guerre civile donc la
triste loi raison il faut attaquer c'est
à dire que l'école doit être
sanctuarisée
les profs doivent être respectées on ne
doit on doit soutenir les profs et la
hiérarchie doit souffrir les profs art
sur un autre sujet qui n'est pas la
violence mais qui hélas faire pâtit
on la voit bien on voit bien que patty a
été abandonné par sa hiérarchie
parce que la hiérarchie ne veut pas
faire de vagues donc maintenant
geografia il faut respecter il faut
respecter les profs un gamin qui ne
respectent pas les profs doit être
sanctionnée dès le primaire
or on a laissé des gamins se comporter
très mal vis-à-vis des profs ne pas
écouter en classe etc
moi de mon temps je vais jouer les vieux
cons mais on se serait pas permis la
moindre marque d'impolitesse vis-à-vis
de l'instituteur parce que ça se serait
très mal passé
aujourd'hui on voit des parents qui
viennent cogner les instituteurs ou les
profs de collège
donc on a finalement diminué laura le
pouvoir le respect des enseignants et
c'est par l'école qu'il faut commencer
je pense que la dimension d'instruction
civique même s'il ne faut pas revenir
aux hussards noirs de la troisième
république est fondamentale donc c'est
pas un combat perdu mais là il faut un
peu de courage
or en réalité d'aller soutenir les
preuves dans les quartiers difficiles
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
notamment parce que certains élus
maintenant bénéficie d'une manne
électorale issue du communautarisme et
n'ose pas attaquer les bars où il ya des
traficant les communautarismes qui ce
qui se développe est puis les violences
qui sont organisés par des groupes
il faut avoir le courage d'aller vers
d'avoir une vision universaliste de
défendre l'école de défendre les profs
et il faut cesser de démissionner faut
je vais vous dire quelque chose auquel
je crois c'est qu'il va falloir un
moment aussi économiquement détruire ce
qui fait en fait le terreau de cette
délinquance et de ses pertes de repères
par rapport au vivre ensemble et à l'art
public donc il faudra un moment se poser
la question le trafic du cannabis
d'accord est ce qu'il vaut mieux pas le
légaliser l'encadré plutôt que de les
laisser aux mains de trafiquants qui
font espérer à des gamins qu'on dise 12
ans quand quittant l'école ils vont
vivre heureux non ils vont ils vont pas
vivre heureux leur vie va être un
cauchemar et on leur fait croire
d'accord les trafiquants sont très doués
pour ça pour leur faire croire d'accord
donc il faut se battre pour ça c est
vraiment c'est là où on se dit la
répression bien sûr la répression bien
sûr la présence de la police a arrêté
une erreur de d'enlever la police de
proximité donc il faut vraiment remettre
la police sur le terrain on est tous
d'accord mais ya pas que ça il ya
l'école ya l'éducation il ya la culture
il ya l'aide sociale qui doit pas être
simplement on donne un billet à la fin
du mois c'est aussi de se dire est-ce
qu'il faut pas des psychothérapeutes eux
il faut pas des psychologues familiale
il faut pas augmenter les moyens aux
plannings familiaux dans certains
quartiers et puis on retombe d'un sur le
fait qu'il faut redynamiser un l'emploi
et l'industrie donc on retombe sur ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure c'est
réindustrialiser la france parce que ça
sa part par là autre chantier ambitieux
mais c'est loin des professeurs à
l'instant est ce que il n'ya pas eu une
forme de naïveté ou d'angélisme chez les
enseignants qui ont voulu abandonner
façon excessive l'autorité et le
maintien de l'ordre disons-le dans leur
classe oui je pense ils ont on a on a eu
un décrochage à mon avis vers la fin des
années 80 quand il y avait il fallait
faire des économies où on a commencé à
dire bah finalement il y avait 20 élèves
par classe on va en mettre 30
et c'est peut-être là où en fait c'est
il ya eu il ya eu ce phénomène de de
décrochage de l'idéologie c'était ça ma
maison venant est un homme de joueurs
oui il ya une théologie alors oui alors
il ya eu des théories je suis j'avais vu
un peu passer ça des théories dix ans il
fallait laisser les enfants faire
fallait les accompagner fallait pas
faire d'excès je pense que c'est la
limite mais là vous retombez sur le le
sempiternel débat qu'on a depuis que
chirac à arrêter le service militaire
c'est est ce qu'il ne faut pas remettre
un service militaire pour tout le monde
macron l'a essayée à mon avis c'est un
échec d'accord et on n'entend plus c'est
qu'on entend plus parler
meda coup et c'est vrai que vous vous
dites d'avoir un filtre douze mois par
an qui permet de recadrer tout le monde
c'est pas de l'endoctrinement c'est pas
c'est juste remettent un curseur du
vivre ensemble et pour moi c'est vous
vous posiez la question est-ce que c'est
foutu non c'est pas foutu si le
politique s'empare du dossier et se dit
bon ben voilà on va bête alors en effet
moi j'approuve totalement quand
blanquaert a vraiment essayé de limiter
les enfants par classe au cp et c est je
trouve qu'il a de bonnes idées pour
relancer justement l'importance de
l'école l'importance de ce que ça veut
dire mais il faut que tout le monde
suive derrière et c'est vrai qu'il ya
des revendications de la part des
enseignants qui sont importantes
on retombe sur tu as tout à fait raison
sur la sphère samuel paty et j'ai
discuté récemment avec une amie qui fait
prof de philo en seine saint denis et
qui le fait vraiment par militantisme et
qui est courageuse et qui me disait mais
il faut venir voir ce que je vis ou d'un
coup il ya des reproches qui sont faits
par rapport à de la matière culturelle
que je le redis et qu'ils ne veulent pas
entendre donc d'un coup il ya il ya le
fait d'écouter et d'entendre un an
ayant qui était vraiment lui je suis sûr
que c'est le vraiment c'est le noyau
atomique de tout ça il ya de très
nombreuses réactions sur sur internet
d'abord vous avez répondu à notre
question twitter sur
cette terrible affaire youri sans
surprise vous considérez à 84% qu'elle
est le symbole ou peut être le reflet de
l'ensauvagement de la société donc je me
concentre sur les internautes qui sont
pas forcément d'accord avec cette idée
bibi sur youtube qui nous dit je pense
qu'une minorité a toujours été violente
et cette violence est mise en exergue
lors des périodes difficiles et avec les
réseaux sociaux et puis alexandre
toujours sur youtube je n'aime pas le
mot ans sauvagement les violences sont
juste plus médiatisé qu'avant ça
n'empire pas je m'empresse de le dire
que ces points de vue sont minoritaires
parce que la plupart d'entre nous
considérait effectivement que il y a un
problème mais chardon bleu sur
lefigaro.fr par le même de laxisme de
l'état
il ya beaucoup de réactions sur cette
réponse pénale nécessaire il faudrait au
minimum cinq ans fermé des peines
planchers nous décrit ce qu il se passe
rien en plaidant à délaisser le régalien
nous narre dans les jours prochains dans
une 14
je comprends je comprends ce que dit
votre internaute là mais il se passe
rien en prison n'oubliez jamais ça vous
vous les mettez en prison ils sortent
plus voyou que ce qui sont rentrés sains
mais peut-être ça peut faire peur ou
laurent alexandre vous n'y croyez même
pas ça 7,7 côte cet aspect dissuasif
le schéma américain a montré que les
peines de prison n'était pas dissuasive
il y à plus de deux millions de
prisonniers dans les prisons américaines
et un taux de délinquance et de crimes
très très très supérieur à ce qu'on a
en ile de france donc le caractère
dissuasif de la prison sur des jeunes
déracinés sans culture qui ont quitté
l'école qui n'ont pas de sens civique et
qui ont été laissées en jachère ce rôle
dissuasif de la prison et là s'il
n'existe pas merci beaucoup à tous les
deux
même si cette émission n'était pas une
tonalité très joyeuse mais parfois
l'actualité ne l'est pas il faut la
regarder en face merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis et à demain pour une
nouvelle édition de point de vue
[Musique]